- There's no shortage
of social media posts
that will put a smile on your face.
My job is to bring you
the best of the best.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
Diapers, formula, wipes, bibs, bottles.
Having a baby has its joys,
but also has the costs.
They can add up real quick, y'all.
One mama here in LA
is trying to make it a
little easier for parents
in a super creative way.
Check this out.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
So far, Crystal and her husband
have tucked away more than a
$1000 for unsuspecting parents.
It's so cool.
We have Crystal on the line right now.
What's up?
(audience applauding)
- Hi Kelly.
- Hi, first of all, you
have such a beautiful heart.
What an amazing thing to do for someone.
Especially like, it's a struggle,
all the costs that it
takes to having a baby,
we all would know.
But how did you come up with this?
- Yeah, so my husband and I are
expecting baby number three.
- Congratulations.
- And, we went...
(audience applauding)
Thank you.
So, we went out shopping for the new baby,
and were so amazed and shocked
at how expensive things have gotten.
And remembered how expensive
they were when we were new parents.
And it's a pandemic, lots
of people are out of work.
And we just couldn't imagine
being in a tough position.
Having to decide between baby
products and, you know, bills.
So, we took all the
money out of our wallet,
and hid it in some baby products.
And we made a day out of it.
We went to the ATM, hit
a couple more stores,
and shared it on social media
in hopes that some local parents in need
would hopefully find it and
get some baby products too.
And we totally didn't
expect it to go viral,
but it did.
- Well, since your post did go viral,
other people are following
in your lead, right?
- Yeah.
We are so shocked
and it really warms our heart
to know that there are
people all over the country
that have been sending us videos,
sharing that they've done the
same thing with their kids,
and it just really warms our heart
to know that there are other people
that were inspired to
share kindness and joyness.
- Oh, absolutely.
Thank you so much, Crystal.
I'm liking your post right now.
(audience applauding)
And that is not all,
our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, the go-to pen
of Kelly Clarkson Show,
thinks what you're doing
is as incredible as we do.
In recognition, they'd
like to write you a check
with their G2 gelling pen for $1000.
How's that sound?
(audience applauding)
- Oh my goodness!
- (Kelly laughs)
- Thank you, oh my God.
- Absolutely.
I believe that what you put
out there comes back to you.
So, thank you so much
for your beautiful heart in this message.
I hope it creates a domino effect.